every parent's worst nightmare july
20th 2012
my phone rings at 4 30 in the morning
it's my son alex's girlfriend amanda
saying hysterically
tom tum there's been a shooting
and they dragged me out of the theater
they wouldn't let me stay i wanted to
leave but they dragged me out
i say to amanda amanda are you okay have
you been hurt
and she said no that she was fine
that alex had saved her life
i then say amanda
where's alex and she says sobbing
i don't know we can't find him they
dragged me out of the theater they made
me leave
he was shot i tried to wake him up but i
couldn't wake him up he wouldn't get up
they dragged me away i didn't want to
leave him
and i say to amanda
the last time you saw alex was he
bleeding
did you have any of his
blood on you
and she cries
lot and breaks down
alex loved amanda and he was one of the
most honorable men on earth
and at the age of 24
he had to make the decision to risk his
life
in order to ensure she would live
i knew in my heart if he couldn't get up
he was dead
i had just arrived the night before
with my wife karen and my youngest son
for a week's vacation in hawaii
we were literally 3 300 miles away
karen and i frantically started calling
his cell phone
to no avail we left multiple messages
we then turned to the media but all we
could find
was information on the murderer and his
booby trap department
we tried calling the aurora police
station
but it was impossible to get an answer
but in hindsight it was understandable
they were dealing with 12
dead 70 injured
the carnage so bad the police had to
bring
some of the victims to the hospitals in
the backs of their police cars because
they had
run out of ambulances
it was a horrific and chaotic scene
we would never see alex again
his injuries so severe had to shield
even his mom from looking upon him
for fear that would be the lasting image
of him
in her mind but you know who we would
see again and again
the murderer his pictures
were everywhere
one article was six paragraphs long
and featured his name 41
times the media
had made him famous
but my firstborn son alex
a hero was absent
from those initial reports
karen and i immediately realized that
there was
something wrong with the way the media
responds to these random mass shootings
since
columbine we started doing research
and we realized that if we could change
the way the media reports we could
reduce the amount of
shootings and save lives
let me explain
almost every single random mass shooter
has something in common can anybody
guess what that is
they want notoriety they want to be
famous in fact
these murderers are telling us
this themselves the sandy hook murderer
kept a spreadsheet of previous
mass murderers and their number of kills
the orlando pulse
nightclub murderer called
a local news station during his attack
and then stopped to check facebook to
see if he'd gone
viral the parkland murderer
posted recorded and posted
a video stating
when you see me on the news you'll know
who i
am the aurora theater
murderer told a psychiatrist that he
recognized he couldn't make an
impact on the world in science
but he could become famous
by blowing people up and most
telling the umpqua community
college murderer wrote on his blog about
about a previous mass murderer saying
i've noticed that people like him
are all alone and unknown but when they
spill a little blood
the whole world knows who they are
a man who was known by no one
is now known by everyone his face
splashed across every screen his name on
the lips
of everyone on the planet
all in one day
it seems like the more people you kill
the more you're in the limelight
these are just a few examples
i could go on and on these murderers are
telling us they want to be famous
like the murderers before them and the
mid
the media continues to give them exactly
what they seek
notoriety
the gun debate is very emotional
and our mental health issues are very
complicated both will
take time to correct
but to reduce the carnage
we don't need an act of congress
what we need is an act of conscience
on the producers and consumers of mass
media to remove the reward of notoriety
so to save lives karen and i launched no
notoriety
dedicated to challenging the media to
protect our communities
by adhering to these research-backed
principles one
report all the facts on the mindset
demographics and motivational profile
of these shooters but minimize their
names and images unless they're at large
two limit the use
of the shooter's name to once per piece
never in the headlines and no pictures
in prominent locations
and three three
i'm not good with numbers
refuse to publish
any self-serving material provided by
the shooters
to be clear this is not an infringement
on anyone's first amendment rights
this is not censorship
we are merely asking the media to
leverage
guidelines they already have in place
for example the media does not report
on journalists that have been kidnapped
in order to protect them
the media does not report the names and
images
of victims of sexual assault
or suicide these responsible
journalistic practices
protect public safety with zero impact
on the public's right to know academic
studies
show that the average
news consumer wants to hear less about
the shooters
instead the media should elevate
the names and images of the victims
both murdered and injured the heroes
and the first responders they should
they should promote data and analysis
from experts on the fields of mental
health
and public safety all the experts agree
the fbi the international police
association
the major city chiefs association
an alert the law enforcement
organization dedicated to training first
responders to
stop active shooters all
endorse the principles of no notoriety
in fact in 2014
the fbi started the don't name them
campaign
in support of the idea the american
psychiatric association
supports reducing and minimizing the
identification of
these shooters the idea has gone
worldwide with the prime minister of new
zealand
calling for no notoriety after the
christchurch shootings
but as much as we want the media to
change
they are for profit organizations
they won't change unless we
hold them accountable
the media makes their money
from advertising based on the number of
viewers and clicks if we can reduce
the number of viewers and clicks
on any subject the media will change the
way they report on it
so the next time you see any media
organization
print digital radio or television
grow gratuitously leveraging the names
and
images of these shooters stop watching
stop listening stop clicking
stop liking and stop sharing
write to the producers
editors station managers and ceos
of these news organizations take note
of the advertisers who support those
segments
and write to their ceos because
together we can push the media to act in
the interest
of public safety not profits
it's too late for alex and it's too late
for my family
but please don't join our club by
inaction
the club nobody wants to join
the dues too high because it's not
too late for people who aren't
victims yet we have the power
to reduce random mass
shootings let's use it
thank you